juristische schlappe für den
verfassungsschutz er darf die afg
vorerst nicht als verdachtsfall
einstufen und beobachten
trauer um die korona toten
bundespräsident steinmeier wirbt bei
einem treffen mit hinterbliebenen für
ein gemeinsames gedenken historische
reise in den irak papst franziskus
besucht als erstes oberhaupt der
katholiken das krisengeschüttelte land
nachrichten des tages heute mit petra
gerster guten abend willkommen bei den
nachrichten am freitag die formen
wintersport hat rudi cerne mitgebracht
den hof mehr dazu später genannt
es war ein paukenschlag am mittwoch der
verfassungsschutz ordne die afg als
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall ein
heute nun kommando zurück das hätte
nicht passieren dürfen denn die partei
wehrt sich gerade vor dem kölner
verwaltungsgericht dagegen als
verdachtsfall eingestuft zu werden
dieses gericht untersagt dem
verfassungsschutz nun ausdrücklich mit
rücksicht auf das laufende verfahren die
afg zu beobachten allerdings nur
vorläufig david guetta hat die afg sieht
es als wichtigen etappensieg im
juristischen langstreckenlauf gegen den
verfassungsschutz das bundesamt darf die
gesamtpartei vorerst nicht als
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall
einordnen und beobachten ich habe selten
eine solche ohrfeige lebt für den
verfassungsschutz
übrigens das zweite mal dass ein gericht
dem verfassungsschutz bescheinigt dass
er offen ct selbst nicht genau weiß was
er da verfassung steht
der inlandsgeheimdienst hatte sich
gegenüber dem kölner gericht unter
anderem verpflichtet über eine mögliche
beobachtung der af die nicht öffentlich
zu berichten
dennoch war mitte der woche die
einstufung der partei als sogenannter
verdachtsfall durchgesickert laut
gerichtsbeschluss ein unlauter eingriff
in die chancengleichheit politischer
parteien
nachdem alles dafür spricht dass sich
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
nicht an die gegebene stillhalte zusage
gehalten bzw nicht hinreichend sorge
getragen hat das keine
verfahrensrelevanten informationen nach
außen dringen und weiter die
vertrauensgrundlage ist nunmehr zerstört
das sind sehr scharfe töne eines
gerichts der verfassungsschutz darf also
die partei vorerst nicht als
verdachtsfall einstufen
das ist aber kein freispruch für die afd
vom vorwurf verfassungsfeindlich zu sein
eine inhaltliche entscheidung
diesbezüglich und über die einstufung
der fdp als verdachtsfall steht noch aus
wird in einigen wochen erwartet
der verfassungsschutz sei etwa in
öffentlichen reden online post und
interviews genug belege gerichte prüfen
sie jetzt für die afg also erstmal nur
eine verschnaufpause
es brodelt in der unionsfraktion im
deutschen bundestag und der druck wächst
einzelne abgeordnete haben in der
pandemie viel geld verdient mit der
beschaffung von schutzmasken eine affäre
die sich ausweitet und jetzt erste
konsequenzen hat der csu politiker georg
nüßlein legt sein amt als vize
fraktionsvorsitzender im bundestag
nieder
das teilte sein anwalt am nachmittag mit
gegen nüßlein laufenden
korruptionsermittlungen der
cdu-abgeordnete nikolas löbel räumte
heute fehler ein
seine firma hatte für die vermittlung
von masken aufträgen etwa 250.000 euro
kassiert tja da wo man das ja ganz
gewaltig in der unionsfraktion schalk
unterlamm energy ja das tut dass wir
haben uns heute hier mal umgehört und
der unmut ist schon erheblich über beide
fälle weil man ganz klar davon ausgeht
dass von beiden fällen das schlechte
image sozusagen abfärbt auf cdu und csu
im ersten fall geht es zwar bisher nur
um den um einen verdachtsfall georg
nüßlein und im zweiten fall nicht um ein
strafrechtlich relevantes handeln
allerdings spielt das hier unterm strich
keine rolle weil in dieser pandemie die
bundestagsabgeordneten schon sehen dass
sie nochmal eine besondere verantwortung
tragen und das ausgerechnet bei der
beschaffung von pandemie gütern hier
einzelne profit machen
das wird hier sehr negativ bewertet und
aus der unionsfraktion heißt es der
schritt wird begrüßt dass georg nüßlein
jetzt sein amt niederlegt und man hofft
damit wahrscheinlich den schaden zu
begrenzen kurz vor zwei wichtigen
landtagswahlen und insgesamt in einer
zeit in der die union sehr untergrund
kritik steht erst mit dem
gesundheitsminister jetzt mit
abgeordneten
vielen dank unterland nach berlin
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
zehn 1580 neuinfektion bin eines tages
das sind knapp 600 mehr als am
vergangenen freitag 264 weitere
todesfälle sind in verbindung mit coop
19 dazu gekommen die sieben tage
incident steigt
auf 65,4 dieser trend soll wieder
gestoppt werden
der gesundheitsminister will endlich
schwung ins testen und impfen bringen
britta spiekermann impfen und testen
sowie die regierung raus aus der
pandemie
doch es funktioniert nicht an vielen
stellen der minister ist angezählt
testat später als geplant durchführung
möglicherweise schwierig wer trägt die
verantwortung dass sich hat mich sehr
bewusst nicht beteiligt an der frage wer
ist jetzt an irgendwas schuld ich könnte
auch viele geschichten erzählen aus den
letzten zwölf monaten
ich glaube einfach nur das hilft nicht
nur knapp drei prozent der bevölkerung
haben bis jetzt zwei impfungen erhalten
dazu kommt eine weitere schlechte
nachricht die virusvariante b 11 7
verbreitet sich schnell
vor vier wochen hat die b 11 7 noch
einen anteil von etwa sechs prozent an
allen untersuchten proben vor zwei
wochen etwas über 20 prozent und in der
letzten woche sind es schon mehr als 40
prozent
ab morgen sind selbst tests auf dem
markt erhältlich wer sie für den
privaten bereich brauchte zahlt selbst
in quito von schulen etwa sollen sie
kostenlos sein
ab montag gibt es dann auch die so
genannten schnelltests für jede bürgerin
jeden bürger mindestens einen pro woche
unter fachlicher anleitung
ich glaube nicht dass das material das
problem ist sondern wer macht es so
kommen die menschen her die schlicht und
ergreifend solche tests durchführen
es warten also neue probleme offenbar
reicht wieder nicht viel ineinander
bund und länder müssen antworten finden
mehr als 70.000 menschen sind in
deutschland bisher im zusammenhang mit
dem corona virus gestorben
mitte april will man in berlin alle
opfer gedenken
heute sprach bundespräsident steinmeier
mit angehörigen über das sterben und
trauern in der pandemie patricia
wiedemeier ihre angehörigen sterben
einsam alleine fünf hinterbliebene
schilderten heute dem bundespräsidenten
ihre zitat endlosen tage des schreckens
was man ja eigentlich braucht vor allen
dingen wenn man sich nicht mehr erholt
und wenn man dann stirbt dann braucht
menschliche gesichter und man braucht
berührung und man braucht jemand der
einem die hand hält und genau das
verhindert er diese krankheit wenn man
so ein so sagt nein du darfst nicht
kommen so obwohl es den körper ist dass
es schon hart
michaela mengels tochter war
schwerbehindert auf die hilfe ihrer
mutter angewiesen als sie an cobit
erkrankte kam sie ins krankenhaus ganz
alleine die mutter durfte erst kurz vor
ihrem tod zu ihr aber da habe ich
gemacht salz starke mutter mich daneben
bestellt meine tochter festgehalten
handy an gemacht musik vorgespielt bosse
der letzte tanz musste sein um dann habe
ich zugeguckt wie mein kind gestorben
ist ja nach elf tagen
das war's dann das letzte wo ich sie
lebend gesehen habe weil ich abend als
ich sie verlassen musste es sind
inzwischen über 70.000 die an oder mit
corona gestorben sind oft alleine aber
auch abschied nehmen trauern gemeinsames
gedenken viele in diesen zeiten so der
bundespräsident
gerade jetzt in einer situation in der
wir in dieser dunklen zeit miteinander
spüren wie verletzlich wir als menschen
sind und wie sehr wir als gemeinschaft
aufeinander angewiesen sind
am 18 april soll es eine nationale
gedenkfeier in berlin geben mit der
stadtspitze und hinterbliebenen ein
kleiner trost von china breitete sich
das virus in der ganzen welt aus aber
das autoritär regierte land hatte mit
drastischen maßnahmen gegengesteuert und
hielt die wirtschaft auch 2020 noch am
wachsen
als einziges land der welt plus 2,3
prozent das ziel für dieses jahr gab der
nationale volkskongress heute bekannt
mehr als 6 prozent
auch hongkong ist thema der einwöchigen
sitzung eine änderung des wahlrechts
soll peking die kontrolle über alle
parlamentskandidaten dort bringen
es ist eine bemerkenswerte reise herbst
franziskus besucht als erstes oberhaupt
der katholiken den irak und spricht von
einer pflicht
gegenüber dem seit vielen jahren
geschundenen land in einer zeit in der
dort das virus tobt sowie seit
jahrzehnten kriege und verfolgung
einst lebten rund 1,5 millionen christen
im irak heute sollen es noch 250.000 bis
400.000 seien über eine immer wieder
verfolgte minderheit und einen
besonderen besuch berichtet uli gack
seit stunden haben sie gewartet endlich
ist der papst gekommen sagen viele eine
historische reise franziskus im irak
schon einmal war ein papstbesuch geplant
vor über 20 jahren von johannes paul den
zweiten abgesagt damals von saddam
hussein
vier tage wird sich franziskus im irak
aufhalten
im mittelpunkt steht der interreligiöse
dialog und die solidarität mit den
christen in diesem krieg zerrissenen
lange genug der gewalt des extremismus
der gruppenbildung der intoleranz gebe
allen bürgern raum die dieses land im
dialog in offener und aufrichtiger
konstruktive auseinandersetzung
gemeinsam aufbauen wollen ein frommer
wunsch in caracas einer der wenigen
verbliebenen christlichen steht im irak
haben sie ihre fans zerstörten kirchen
wieder errichtet
probe für den papstbesuch hier am
sonntag kaum jemand mit maske
man habe schlimmeres als co-lead erlebt
glauben wulff
sie hoffen auf solidarität auf
zuversicht auf die kraft des papstes und
resi ambrassat opas frieden kommt dass
sicherheit und stabilität besser werden
im ganzen irak symbolisch für die
angespannte lage das gebet in der
kathedrale bagdad franziskus erinnert
dann dutzende
die hier vor zehn jahren von al kaida
getötet wurden viele christen sind seite
geflüchtet ein exodus ohne ende
zurück nach deutschland und zum
atomausstieg der bund und die
energiekonzerne haben sich nun auf die
höhe der entschädigungen geeinigt
die unternehmen bekommen insgesamt 2,4
milliarden euro als ausgleich etwa für
entgangene gewinne
damit endet ein jahrelanger rechtsstreit
der vorzeitige atomausstieg in
deutschland war 2011 beschlossen worden
nach dem reaktorunglück von fukushima
dem bürger so manchen gang zu den
behörden erleichtern das soll die neue
bürger identifikationsnummer nach dem
bundestag hat nun auch der bundesrat ein
entsprechendes gesetz gebilligt
aus der bisherigen steuer id wird wenn
die bürgerinnen und bürger zustimmen die
bürger die eine nummer für alle
behördengänge
so soll bürokratische aufwand vermindert
werden wann genau sie kommt ist
allerdings noch unklar
und wir kommen zu unserem politbarometer
extra eine gute woche vor den
landtagswahlen in rheinland pfalz und
baden württemberg natürlich besonders
spannend hallo matthias guten anbieter
gehen wir zuerst mal nach rheinland
pfalz und zur ministerpräsidentin der
spd und ihrer partei wie sieht es da aus
naja fast 60 prozent wünschen sich dass
malu dreyer ministerpräsidentin bleibt
ihre beliebtheit nutzt der spd die aber
auch als kompetent bei den wichtigsten
themen gilt das sehen wir hier ein gutes
management der korona krise trauen der
spd 38 prozent zu der cdu nur 17 prozent
und auch bei den themen bildung und
wirtschaft liegen die sozialdemokraten
formen wenn am sonntag landtagswahl wäre
käme die spd auf 33 prozent plus 2
gegenüber der umfrage vor vier wochen
cdu 29 - 4
af den neuen fdp 7 beide +2 grüne 11
minus 2 linke drei freie wähler 4
prozent das würde reichen für eine
fortsetzung der roten ampel und wie sind
die aussichten für ministerpräsident
kretschmann und seine grünen in baden
württemberg der der einzige grüne
ministerpräsident in deutschland der ist
ein pfund für seine partei satte 70
prozent wollen dass er regierungschef
bleibt nur elf prozent wünschen sich
susanne eisenmann von der cdu selbst die
anhänger der cdu bevorzugung mit
deutlicher mehrheit kretschmann im
ländle hat jeder wähler hat jede
wählerin nur eine stimme wer kretschmann
will muss grün wählen wenn am sonntag
landtagswahl wäre würden die grünen mit
35 prozent klar stärkste partei
cdu 24 mit deutlichen verlusten in den
letzten wochen afd 11 spd 10 fdp auf 10
plus 1 die linke 3 prozent das würde
dann reichen für grün-schwarz aber auch
für eine grüne ampel weil das ist keine
prognose sondern ein stimmungsbild
vielen dank dafür
matthias wahlkampf im jahr 2021 das
heißt auch keine kundgebungen mit
berliner politprominenz keine info
stände in fußgängerzonen was es gibt
sind die vielen wahlplakate und flyer in
den briefkästen
vor allem aber ist der wahlkampf digital
aus stuttgart berichtet andreas linke
der wahlkampf im netz er braucht
vorbereitung zum beispiel die runde der
spitzenkandidaten die die stuttgarter
nachrichten veranstalteten
meinungsbildung auf digitalem weg das
geht aber hat auch schwächen sagt der
gastgeber
was wir natürlich nicht simulieren
können sind wirklich spontane reaktion
wie sie die in
im großen saal mit großem publikum im
arm und das ist schon etwas wenn man
gewisse vorprägung durch die erfahrung
viele wahlkämpfe die mir begleitet hat
hat dann fällt da was die parteien
selbst versuchen die unterschiedlichsten
wege zu bespielen inklusive des
sogenannten micro tage tings also
spezielle werbung für spezielle
zielgruppen die seite funktioniert gut
aber es gibt ja unterschiede auf der
seite der wählerinnen und wähler die
einen sind internet affiner vor allem
die jüngeren und die anderen nicht und
das macht es schwerer für die parteien
die ähren älteres publikum haben und wie
sehen wähle den so anderen wahlkampf da
hört man gar nicht so viel zu wenig wenn
man überlegt dass nächste woche wahlen
sind man hätte natürlich die möglichkeit
sich im internet alles möglich an
informationen zu besorgen nur wer tut
also das ist dann eher was ich lokal in
der zeitung lese digital
das ist das kommt bei mir zumindest so
nicht nicht an
aber es gibt ja auch noch herkömmliche
wahlwerbung digitales für plakate und
briefkasten broschüren haben die
parteien ebenso erhöht wie den fürs
digitale was die parteien wollen und wie
gut oder schlecht sie miteinander können
analysen und hintergründe finden sie in
unserer zdf heute app für baden
württemberg und rheinland pfalz zusammen
mit dem wahlomat für noch
unentschlossene
er galt als einer der ganz großen im
deutschen filmgeschäft dieter wedel
jetzt hat die münchner
staatsanwaltschaft anklage erhoben
dem 81 jährigen wird vorgeworfen 1996
eine schauspielerin vergewaltigt zu
haben
bei einem vorstellungsgespräch im hotel
mädel bestreitet die vorwürfe
jetzt noch zur berlinale die heute schon
ihre gewinner bekannt gab
auch wenn diesmal wegen corona die filme
erst im sommer vor großem publikum
gezeigt werden der goldene bär für den
besten film ging an bett lag ging oder
uhr unicorn aus rumänien darin landet
dass privates sexvideo eine
lehrerin im internet beste
schauspielerin ist die deutsche marine
eckert ausgezeichnet für ihre rolle in
der melancholischen zukunftsvision ich
bin ein mensch und jetzt zum intersport
mit pudel im schneetreiben im allgäu
karl geiger gewinns bei den nordischen
ski-weltmeisterschaften in oberstdorf
bereits seine dritte medaille bronze auf
der großschanze weltmeister wird der
österreicher stefan kraft alles
rausgeholt aus dem zweiten sprung mit
132 metern sichert sich karl geiger auf
seiner heimschanze wm bronze gold geht
an österreich stefan kraft schreit alles
raus nach einer ausnahme saison mit 19
erkrankung wird ja mit 134 metern im
zweiten sprung überraschend weltmeister
silber geht an die norweger robert
johansson für titelverteidiger markus
eisenbichler lief es mit platz 17 nicht
so gut er stürzte nach dem zweiten
sprung zum glück ist nichts passiert und
jubel bei den deutschen biathleten die
männer staffel gewinnt erstmals seit
vier jahren ein weltcup rennen
das quartett mit erik lesser benedikt
doll arnd peiffer und philipp nawrath
setzt sich am nachmittag in nowe miasto
in tschechien souverän gegen die
konkurrenz durch und siegt vor russland
und norwegen so und in der
fußball-bundesliga kommt es morgen zum
duell der beiden prägenden teams des
letzten jahrzehnts bayern münchen gegen
borussia dortmund erster gegen fünfter
bvb-trainer edin terzic sieht gute
chancen den spitzenreiter aus dem tritt
zu bringen
denn es läuft derzeit für den test schon
seine borussia in liga und pokal vom
bayern-spiel appelliert der trainer an
die moral
das ist bei uns immer ein großes thema
dafür steht borussia dortmund wenn wir
das gefühl haben ein bisschen weniger zu
machen dann wird es in jeder aufgabe für
uns extrem schwer
der bvb der ohne handschuhe und gregor
auskommen muss gegen die bayern die die
letzten bundesliga heimspiele gegen
dortmund bequem und locker gewonnen
haben wir haben enorme qualität in der
offensive genauso wie das dortmund auch
hat und klar ist natürlich auch dass es
immer wichtig ist eine gute eine gute
defensive zu haben
daran arbeiten wir bayern gegen dortmund
lewandowski trifft auf holland wer mehr
grund zur freude hat sehen wir morgen ja
und dieses topspiel dann ausführlich
morgen im aktuellen sportstudio bitte
danke
und jetzt noch zu einer gigantischen bau
aktion in nordrhein-westfalen der
autobahnbrücke an der a 45 bei hagen
knapp ein kilometer fahrbahn die heute
in ihre finale position geschoben wurde
was im zeitraffer recht zügig passiert
dauert in echtzeit fast den ganzen tag
20 meter in 6 stunden ein tonnenschwerer
koloss unterwegs im schneckentempo ja
der winter ist im eiltempo zurück heute
nacht erwarten uns temperaturen bis
minus zehn grad mehr dazu gleich beim
wetter mit festen termin so viel von uns
mehr gibt es im heute journal mit claus
kleber umziehen
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen noch einen entspannten
freitagabend bis morgen 19 uhr tschüss